if you thought your family dinners were
bad just wait until this week's episode
of House of the Dragon just try to do a
better job at holding your tongue than
vehment with only three more episodes
left House of the Dragon ramps up toward
the finale and oh my God how is he still
alive for those of you new here this is
a deep dive into the episode its
connection to Game of Thrones and
completely inappropriate memes he can
keep his tongue
God damn right and don't worry this
video contains no book spoilers Beyond
this episode so come back with me to
King's Landing where everything is
perfect and absolutely nothing can go
wrong it's been six years since rhaenys
last saw her husband lord of the tides
Corliss Valerian after the death of his
son and daughter it seems as though he
set his eyes on Conquest remember this
is a man who said history remembers
names not blood and he solidified his
name in wealth through his nine great
voyages and what better way to take out
the anger for the loss of your children
by slaying playing some Pirates
unfortunately for Corliss it's landed
him with a grave entry after he was
ambushed he survived a hit by a
corsair's dagger but has fallen Gravely
ill to fever in the book there's no such
Ambush he just gets a fever and doesn't
fully recover for almost three years
regardless this whole event calls into
question who gets drift marked after he
passes now this shouldn't even be an
issue Corliss has made it clear his
grandson luceris is to be lord of the
tides after his passing even though
we'll later find out from master of laws
Jasper Wilde that Corliss has never
officially stated this last episode
Corliss told young Luke that driftmark
is one day to be his and even double
downed on his decision when rhaenis
offered another option that of Bala
taking over this whole debacle would
have been an open and shut case if it
weren't for those like vaman valarian
questioning the legitimacy of Luke's
Birthright believing him not to be the
legitimate son of Lenor rather that of
Harwin strong in vaman's mind driftmark
should remain in the hands of a valorean
and not a bastard rhaenis even tells him
to watch his tongue for what he's saying
is tantamount to treason The Raven
telling of corliss's injury was received
by maester Kelvin a character created
for the show and loyal to house valarian
it came from evenfall which is about a
three-day Journey south of driftmark
even fall Hall is the home of house
Tarth and where Brienne of Tarth was
trained just don't tell tormund behind
rhaenice is her granddaughter Vela who
has assumed the position of War at face
value it seems a kind gesture so that
the queen Who Never Was gets to spend
time with her granddaughter but it's far
more strategic it allows Damon and
Rainier to have eyes and ears on what's
happening in driftmark for it is Bala
who warns her father of vaman's plan to
usurp Luke from the Driftwood Throne
vamund essentially tells his
sister-in-law that he'll do this with or
without her help he has much stronger
allies who would be sympathetic to his
plight it's far better for the
hightowers to have Raymond on the
Driftwood Throne than raniera's son Luke
and even tells them in secret if he were
to have driftmark he would forever be in
their debt among the crevices of
Dragonstone Damon descends into the
caves to find three new eggs from
Rainier's Dragon Cyrax remember that
Dragonstone was built around an active
volcano called dragonmont making it the
perfect layer for several wild or
riderless dragons in the book before the
event known as the dance of dragons six
wild or semi-wild dragons called
dragonmont home most of these we haven't
seen yet like the cannibal Gray Ghost
sheep stealer Silver Wing and a
vermuthor but sea smoke whose Rider
Lenor faked his own death resides there
now too I hope you like your eggs black
and gooey these three are a perfect
match for rhaenyra and Damon's three new
children since we last saw them Ranier
has given birth to two boys with a third
child on the way and these eggs will
undoubtedly be reserved for them we get
to see these boys later on in the
episode and it is said Allison grew
angry when she learned that rhaenyra had
also named one of her children aegon
their second born they named viserys
after the king himself Damon gives the
eggs over to the dragon Tamers who also
have these really sweet Dragon glass
daggers Dragon glass being native to the
island and one of a few materials that
could kill White Walkers it seems having
Bayla as renice's ward has paid off as
she sends word of Raymond's plan to
usurp the Driftwood Throne I tried my
best to decipher the message and this is
what I got father I write with news of
Uncle Raymond who this moment sails for
King's Landing he plans to blank his
grace the king in matters of secession
rights and the sanctity of blood he
wishes for the Driftwood Throne to pass
to him that is his by rights and that he
is the only untainted choice meanwhile
Jace is having as much trouble learning
High Valerian as I did High School
French training him is maester gerardus
who we saw briefly last episode at demon
and raniera's wedding in the book he
becomes a more important character so
keep your eye on him we also get the
briefest glimpse of Joffrey valarin who
he saw as a baby in in episode 6. I
really liked how Jace is trying his best
to learn even though it's quite
difficult with him saying a king should
honor the traditions of his forebears
remember that at this moment Jace is
second in line to the throne after his
mother Damon comes bearing the bad news
from drift Mark vehman is on his way to
King's Landing to make common cause with
the high towers and they just can't let
that happen so for the first time in six
years the targaryens head back to the
red keep to put a stop to this nonsense
once and for all and just like no one
was there to greet the king at driftmark
in episode 5 no one's there to greet
rhaenyra the future friggin Queen there
is an exception however Lord Caswell who
we saw briefly in episode 6 congratulate
the princess on her child the pitiful
greeting is a calculated move by Otto
who will later tell sir Harold
westerling he trusts the princess was
welcomed in a manner befitting her
station as Damon will later note there
have been a few changes to the red keep
since we last saw it many of the
Targaryen heraldry has been taken down
in replaced with religious symbols like
the seven-pointed star we'll see Alison
wear a seven-pointed star necklace she's
always been a bit religious as we saw
her pray in episode 2. it's also a good
strategic move as the faith of the seven
is westeros's dominant religion and her
piety and righteousness Will Curry favor
among the common folk Allison seems to
be leading the small Council on her
husband's behalf in attendance are Lord
Lyman beesbury master of coin Lord
Thailand Lannister master of ships Grand
maester Orwell hand of the king Otto
Hightower and this guy Lord Jasper Wilde
master of laws the big topic of
conversation is driftmark and we kind of
get a sense of which members of the
council are team Allison the greens or
team rhaenyra the blacks Lord Wilde who
coincidentally wears green here is all
for vaman taking control of driftmark
while Lord beesberry wearing black
believes the matter has already been
settled Lucas Lane or son and should get
the throne it's pretty safe to say that
the council looks pretty stacked in
Allison's favor and the name of the next
episode is even called the green Council
so things aren't looking too great if
you're a rhaenyra the matter of
driftmark will be settled tomorrow when
Otto and Allison will hear all the
claimants but where is the king let's
just say the man is one step from
becoming a dead ringer for the Crypt
Keeper his giant model of Hive valyria
is covered in cobwebs and the drapes
covering the king's bed look like these
webs as well we've seen this model
become a metaphor for viserys's life as
it comes to completion so too does his
life that's gonna be one hell of a thing
to remove when he dies so Damon and
renera visit the king who they haven't
seen for years and Damon wastes no time
getting straight to business vehemond is
about to usurp his grandson's claim to
driftmark at first the king's like oh
Otto will take care of it but he doesn't
really comprehend the extent the
hightowers are undermining his rule I
was also interested to see just how far
gone the king's mental capacity had gone
considering last episode he called
Allison Emma the king is also introduced
to his grandchildren aegon and viserys
but when they start crying it's like
migraine City for the king he asks for
his special tea which Damon later
investigates and believes to be milk of
the poppy a drink used to ease pain this
tea can also cause hallucinations dreams
and sleepiness which is great if you're
the high towers and want to rule the
kingdom while the king slowly dies we'll
see the king refuse this team multiple
times later in the episode for he wants
to be as alert as possible during the
hearings and his final Supper The Queen
Is notified of a delicate situation
involving her son aegon this is told to
her by a member of the kingsguard Sir
Eric Cargill not to be confused with
Eric Cargill his twin brother who also
happens to be a member of the kingsguard
just to make it a little easier here are
the two at the UK premiere of House of
the Dragon Talia one of Allison's
trusted handmaidens has brought forth
another handmaiden by the name of Diana
in order not to get demonetized let's
just say aegon and overextended his
Royal Powers this scene really shows us
just how far Allison is willing to go to
protect her children essentially
threatening this young girl who has gone
through an absolutely traumatic
experience and then buying her off with
some gold now we do know aegon has
always had eyes for the ladies this was
set up all the way in episode 6 when
he'd rather focus on the handmaidens
than his sword play the servants even
Scurry away from him foreshadowing just
how creepy he is Diana is also given
some of that sweet sweet Moon tea the
same tea given to renira at the end of
episode 4 which is set to get rid of any
unwanted pregnancies in the book aegon
is said to a father two bastard children
one from a girl whose maidenhood he won
at auction on the street of silk and the
other one one of his mother's
maidservants so it looks like Diana's
story here is plucked straight from the
book Allison has to chastise her son in
yet another awkward scene where he's
naked and it seems Alison is more
concerned on the shame aegon has brought
upon her and is now sister wife Helena
than the actual act he committed she
even goes so far as to say he's no son
of hers which is pretty funny
considering she's gone through all this
[ __ ] to just put him on the throne but
for aegon it seems no matter how hard he
tries he'll never be good enough for her
and father Elena comes in for a brief
moment and Allison gives her a huge hug
almost as if to say you don't deserve
this rhaenyra and Damon meet with the
queen for the first time since Allison
slashed her forearm at driftmark a small
price to pay considering Eamon to Lost
His Eye an even smaller price to pay for
gaining a dragon Damon is concerned the
king is being kept addled by milk of the
poppy and that the high Towers have
become the de facto rulers of the
Kingdom this is even more concerning
considering it will be Otto who makes
the decision on who will become heir to
driftmark hardly fair Allison
understands this and says the father
will be just it's a kind of play on
words the father referring to one of the
seven faces of the seven who are one the
god followed by those of the faith and
her actual father in the faith the
father represents Justice here's a bit
of trivia for this episode there are
three other faces mentioned in this
episode one by rainis and two by viserys
can you name them I'll have the answers
near the end of the video Jason Luke
head to the Courtyard where Harwin
strong beat up Sir Kristen many moons
ago and everyone is looking at them like
they're Outsiders a they haven't been
seen in King's Landing for years and B
they believe Jace and Luke to be
bastards no doubt Rumor Has spread
around the keep that the issue of
driftmark will be brought up tomorrow
and thus Luke's legitimacy Luke says no
one would question him being Heir if he
looked more like Lenor but Jace tells
him it doesn't matter what the people
think this Echoes the exact same thing
raniera said of the people in episode 4.
no want to have no consequence of note
is this Chunk in the wall that Luke made
when he stole sir Kristen's Morning Star
speaking of that morning star sir
Christian trains with a much more Adept
Amen to actually best soon in the book
it said that quote despite the loss of
his eye Eamonn became a Prof efficient
and dangerous Swordsmen under the
tutelage of Sir Kristen Cole but
remained a wild and willful child hot
tempered and unforgiving we'll
definitely get to see this wild and hot
temper manifest later in the episode
it's got to be pretty scary meeting
Eamonn since the last time these two saw
their Uncle Luke had torn out his eye
but before anything can go down they're
interrupted by the arrival of vaman
valarian and vaman looks at Luke like
in a private meeting vaman treats the
hand and the queen to name him air after
all with war on the horizon would they
want a child commanding their Fleet of
ships remember that the triarchy who
vaman himself battled alongside his
brother nephew and Damon has Allied
itself with Dorne so War could break out
at any time at driftmark with an
indebted vament at the helm would be far
more advantageous to the high Towers
than Luke I also like how the director
chose to frame Allison's here almost as
if she's some Caged Bird remember in
episode 4 Rainier equated Allison to
being imprisoned in a castle having to
squeeze out heirs like many important
conversations throughout the season we
have rhaenyra and rhaenis in front of
the werewood tree it is said that the
old gods watch through the carved faces
on their trunks which is why important
ceremonies are often held in front of
them like the oath of the Night's Watch
for example rhaenyra has come with an
offer back Luke's claim to driftmark and
she will betroth Jason Luke to Bella and
Reina Bayla would become Queen of the
Seven Kingdoms and her children heirs to
the throne while Reina will rule in
driftmark as Luke's wife this is all
kind of ironic since rhaenyra once
accused her own father of using her as a
political Pawn to be married off now
she's doing the same thing this is a
desperate tactic by renera who did the
same thing in episode 6 offering Jace's
hand in marriage to Helena an offer
which Allison rejected but rhaenis isn't
going to accept this outright she
believes after all that rhaenyra and
Damon had Lenor killed so that they
could wed I mean it doesn't look good
when the day after Lenor is killed they
allow lope in secret and just like we're
near a swore on the memory of her mother
that her maidenhood was still intact a
pig fat lie she does the same thing to
rainis here swearing on her mother's
memory she did not kill Lenor and
Technically she's right he's probably
hitting up the hottest new clubs in
essos also fun to note here that rhaenis
is wearing black a little nod to what
side she's likely to back unsure whether
Raines will accept her offer rhaenyra
visits her ailing father if he so
believed in aegon the conqueror's
prophecy that a Targaryen will need to
be on the throne to unite the realm
against a great threat why did he name
her Heir and further divide the realm
she essentially tells her father that if
he wishes her to Bear the burden of the
crown then he must man up and defend her
an ominous thunderstorm foreshadows
what's to come we even see a rat on the
Valerian model these rats have proven to
be ill Omens in episodes past like the
ones we saw before renera had her Knight
on the street of silk the one who drank
blood at Lenor and Rainier's wedding or
the one who scammed viserys's chamber
before the deaths of Harwin and Lionel
strong as the king's bandages are
prepped we get to see just how bad the
king's Health has declined and he asks
Otto to arrange supper for everyone
tomorrow evening since this is a special
occasion where his entire family will
finally be together the next day Otto
acting on the king's behalf oversees the
matter of drift Mark it's a sham hearing
with the hightowers knowing full well
they'll support vehement vaman Begins by
talking about how valorian blood goes
even further back than the targaryens
when it comes to settling in Westeros
and that he is the closest kin to
Corliss but rhaenyra fires back that the
same blood courses through the veins of
her children and vehemond only cares
about his own ambition rhaenyra barely
begins her claim when the Great Hall is
interrupted by the king himself who's
like I thought I was dead he's got this
sick gold mask which will later see
covers a missing eye and cheek for
Ellison's sake I hope he's stopped with
those late night booty calls the journey
to sit on the throne is extra extremely
taxing for someone in the king's
condition and there's a heartwarming
moment where his brother helps him up
and even puts his crown on his head
Damon's always wanted just to be by his
brother's side for the king driftmark is
a settled matter and the only person who
can offer any additional Insight is
rhaenys and rainy sides with rhaenyra
telling everyone in attendance that it
was always her and corliss's wish that
driftmark passed to Lenor and his
trueborn son Luke but we kind of know
this is [ __ ] at least on rhenice's
part since she tried to convince Corliss
to make Baila air and not Luke rhaenis
goes one step further and announces the
betrothal of Jason Luke with Bela and
Reina it was just hilarious to see
Allison and Otto's faces here but check
out aegons he lets out this slight grin
I think for aegon it's fun to see
someone sticking it to his mom so the
king settles the matter that Luke is to
remain heir to the Driftwood throne but
vaman stops in and I'm like quiet quiet
is gonna say something vehement won't
allow the king to dictate how his house
is run and for a non-valarnian to take
over as his temper Rises Damon is just
chomping at the bit for vaman to say
those treasonous lines
her children say it a bastards and
faster than you can say Ned Stark
vaymond is beheaded everyone is in
complete shock but death was certain for
vehemence after his Outburst Damon just
got to it first cutting him with his
Valerian steel sword Dark sister in the
book this event doesn't happen in such a
public setting basically renira heard
vaman was talking [ __ ] and had Damon cut
off his head and feed his body to
caraxis you may have also noticed how
Eamon looks at Damon here the two will
share another odd semi-showdown later in
the episode if you read the book you'll
know what's to come of these two but
this is a non-spoiler review just know
that the showrunners here are already
starting to sprinkle in little hints at
things to come this whole ordeal has
made the king incredibly tired if you
listen closely you can barely make out
him saying the line I must put things
right in the book King viserys is
depicted in his old age as being fat and
red of face so what we see in the show
is certainly a departure and take a look
at this brilliant blacks versus The
Greens juxtaposition here the silent
sisters prepare Raymond's body to be
sent back to driftmark you may remember
these silent sisters as having performed
rituals over the body of hand of the
king John Aaron in episode 1 of Game of
Thrones Master Orwell recommends that
rhaenis not look upon the body for fear
the stranger may visit her The Stranger
is one of those seven faces I talked
about earlier and leads the dead to the
other world and what better way to
celebrate than a post beheading Feast we
have the greens on the left and the
blacks on the right and I love this shot
of Allison and raniera apart from one
another with an image of King's Landing
in the center these two women are
fighting for its control and this is
exactly how I want to arrive at dinner
he's even got a sweet Dragon cane the
prayer before dinner seems to be
something new and the King prays to the
two other faces of the seven the mother
and the Smith the mother offers love and
protection something he wants for all
his children and the Smith is the mender
of broken things so of course he wants
Allison and radera to amend their
relationship the king toasted Jason Luke
and their newly betrothed and aegon is
like Well Done Jason finally get to lie
with a woman well aegon at least he'll
be able to lay with a woman consensually
you'll see that Otto here does not drink
to this toast the little bitter [ __ ]
that he is and the King doing his best
Phantom of the Opera impression takes
off his master reveal just how bad
things are he wants all of them to see
him for what he is and he knows his time
is running out if the crown is to remain
strong they will need to set aside their
Grievances and for a moment it looks
like there's a hint of reconciliation
they are both mothers who love their
children and have more in common than
they allow Allison even says rainyro
will make a fine Queen if only their
kids could take notes from their mothers
aegon tells Bala if Jace doesn't satisfy
her she knows who to go to which almost
Sparks a brawl and meanwhile Helena is
just randomly playing with a bug at the
table she'll later toast abela and Lena
saying marriage isn't that bad your
husband will most likely ignore you
unless he's drunk so yeah that doesn't
pay the the greatest of pictures for her
marriage with aegon I did like it how
she then asked Chase to dance just to
stick it to Prince scumbag and for a
very brief moment the king looks at his
family and sees that all is relatively
well this is the last moment he'll have
with him before he dies and it's
probably a good thing considering how
things go downhill after he leaves now
we don't actually get visual
confirmation that King dies this episode
but I think it's pretty safe to say so
with the King clocked out for the night
a pig is brought before Eamonn a fun jab
at the prince who has once gifted the
pig pink dread when he never had a
dragon for Eamonn this is the last straw
he toasts to the boys calling them
handsome wise and strong a play on words
for being Harwin Strong's bastards and
Luke like father like son gets smashed
into a table as the dust settles
rhaenyra thinks it's best they return to
Dragonstone but Allison says she's only
just arrived and I actually found this
to be quite genuine so renira agrees
she'll drop the kids off back home and
then come back via dragon it's probably
a good call since her father could pass
any day and she'll be required to ascend
the throne upon his death in the book
this plays out a little differently but
I'll get to that next episode meanwhile
somewhere in King's Landing Talya meets
with the white worm massaria essentially
confirming that she is one of the white
worms spies and it looks like messaria
has really made a name for herself in
nice clothes a nice home and Talia even
refers to her as lady whether this means
she's married a noble or is just super
rich is yet to be determined missarya
has already learned that it's been quite
the night at the castle perhaps this was
picked up by another one of her spies
now Talia was a character created just
for the show so there's not much we can
glean from the book here on what's going
on however I do have my theories which
I'll save for my preview breakdown with
the King on his last legs Allison gives
him some tea to ease the pain I love
this shot showing one side of his face
with his mask in the foreground now the
king is pretty delusional here and
starts talking about aegon the
conqueror's prophecy but Alison thinks
he's talking about their son aegon
remember that Allison wouldn't know
anything about this prophecy since it's
a secret passed only from Air to air
while referencing aegon's dream he says
things like it is you you are the one
you must do this and he also apologizes
for something that of which we don't
know Allison's gonna interpret this as
the king changing his mind on who should
be king and after he says You must do
this she says I understand my king so we
can basically throw out any of that
reconciliation we thought we could have
between Allison and renera she leaves
the king and he reaches up towards
something with his last words being my
love I like to think that in his
delirium he's reaching for Emma we know
that Emma has always been viserys's true
love even while married to Allison he
kept a ring and would kiss it so if the
king is in fact dead which I believe he
is you can see how it'll be a bit
strange with Rainier having just left
King's Landing giving the high Towers a
bit of a head start should they choose
to steal the throne with renera
potentially on a ship for several days
than having to come back who knows how
long it will be before she actually
finds out her dad has passed if you're
asking me the dance of the Dragons is
about to begin marking one of the
bloodiest time periods in all of
westerosi history I hope you'll consider
liking and subscribing to the channel as
I'll be covering the whole thing stay
tuned for my preview breakdown and let
me know what you thought of the episode
for more bad takes you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at thinkstory YT
until next time remember he can keep his
tongue